[Music]
hi I'm kelcie Hightower a staff
developer advocate for Google cloud
platform and I'm our madhavgarh
co-founder and CTO of hash report this
is the first video in our series
covering open source tools from hashey
Corp and how we can use them with Google
cloud platform in the next few videos
you're gonna learn about using vagrant
packer and terraform with GCP Arman can
you briefly explain those videos sure
you know favorite is a pretty popular
tool that many people love it may be
played with or at least heard of and
it's commonly used to bring up a
development environment in a quick
repeatable manner Packer falls sort of
right after that helping people to build
build those machine images and build
those sort of environments either for
development so build images for vagrant
or to build production oriented images
for example a GCP a VM image and then
terraform is kind of next on the kind of
development to production lifecycle and
it helps people provision infrastructure
whether that's you know a vSphere
cluster locally or a GCP cluster on the
cloud so if I'm gonna use them here and
all these tools I'm like that's a lot of
puzzle pieces can you touch on how you
type all these tools together sure I
think this really goes back to kind of
our mission at ha sure but why the
company even exists when we started the
company it was really to look at that
application delivery process from
development through to production and
say like what are those pieces that you
really need that like necessary and
sufficient components and then building
an open-source tool to do each of those
things so that you can provision secure
and run any type of infrastructure for
any type of application awesome and
users who I know have played with hashey
Corp tools they all tell me it's like
all the tools have a similar look and
feel is there a common approach you take
to building these tools yeah I'm glad
you asked there's a document we've
published called the Tao of Hasek or
where we talk about what the design
principles and kind of the core
philosophy is behind kind of our
approach to infrastructure as well as
our approach to actually building tools
and you know that comes across and kind
of the look and feel of the tools
themselves so I think that's one thing
that says hashey core part is how this
look and feel the tools are can you talk
about some of the principles behind that
look and feel sure you know we outlined
all of them in the Tao
there's maybe six or seven of them but I
think the three that are kind of the
most important for people is a focus on
workflows infrastructure is code and
immutability
the workflow focus for us is very very
important because our view is that users
are gonna bring their own technology
right so some users they're gonna be you
know living in a world of vSphere and
on-premise and how do we meet them there
and other users are gonna be fully in
the cloud running everything in GCP and
how do we support that and other people
are gonna cross this entire spectrum so
that's sort of our focus on workflow as
opposed to technology and then when we
get to immutability the idea is how do
we avoid changing our applications our
machines our you know infrastructure in
place where we might introduce errors
into production and cause things to fail
and sort of unexpected ways and instead
build brand new versions that we fully
know and understand and can vet and I
think then the third kind of most
important one is this notion of
infrastructure as code which is another
technique to to kind of manage the
complexity and make sure we can you know
go to large-scale in the same way so I
have a lot of experience with
infrastructure as code but maybe for
some of the people out there watching if
you give it a little bit more detail
about what infrastructure as code is and
what it means to hashey Corp yeah it's a
you know I think it's a pretty general
idea it can apply to all sorts of things
but I think the kernel of it is this
notion that you know what we're used to
is having sort of in our heads the idea
of how our development environment is
built how our clusters are managed and
what we're really trying to do is take
that that's locked away in our head and
bring it in and have it live as code
that actually can be executed right and
this way we could version control it we
can reuse it we can share it with one
another we can extend it over time and
we can really begin to apply the best
practices of software development to
infrastructure management right and so
the goal is to kind of get away from the
oral tradition or you're like you know
Bob and the coroner really knows how
everything works and nobody else does
all right so let's be honest like is
this technique unique to terraform or do
you see this technique in other places
so it's a bit loaded because I know you
used to work at puppet but you know I
think to give credit where credit's due
I think this idea was really first
pioneered by the config management
community where they really realized
that it's getting increasingly
complicated to manage your modern server
so just understanding users and packages
and files and directories and
permissions
is too much so how do we have all of
that live as code and be able to manage
our servers in this programmatic way so
I think the config management community
really pioneered it and now we've taken
that and are applying it to sort of the
broader Hacha core tool chain awesome so
you talked about this focus on workflows
how does that focus on workflows affect
Hoshi Corp and GCP yeah that's a great
question you know like I said for us
it's this belief that we have to meet
our users where they are in terms of
their technology choices and for us a
huge part of our community lives and
operates and consumes GCP so for us it's
really important to make sure with
vagrant you can have a development box
in GCP with Packer you can build images
for terraform you can manage your GCP
clusters so on and so forth it's that
all of the tool chains should integrate
with GCP because that's a technology
choice of users want to make all right
so hey thanks Arman for joining me today
how can more people learn about more of
Hoshi Corp tools and the philosophy
behind her she Corp yeah thanks for
having me it's always a pleasure Kelsie
I'd recommend people visit our homepage
Hasek or comm to learn more about the
company and the tools or alternatively
people can just watch your talk on
YouTube that you gave at Hoshi comp
about delivering a 12 factor app with
the Hashi stack cool so hey thanks
everyone for watching don't forget to
subscribe to the channel to keep up with
more the open source videos in this
series we got more to come for how you
can use other open source tools but GCP
[Music]
alright thanks for watching make sure to
check out these other cool videos on the
channel and don't forget to subscribe